I'm not sure who started this but
everyone began to Echo it the 2020
election was the most secure election in
history you probably heard it you
probably heard it many times and the
first question you have to ask is a
how would you know that and number two
it's one thing to say we had an election
we haven't seen enough proof of fraud
but to actually make a positive claim
that this was the most secure election
requires you to now produce evidence
showing that there was less fraud in
2020 than in the previous elections
right that's what that statement means
less fraud in 2020 compared to 2016 2012
2008 2004. so ask yourself how do you
measure and what did you do and how did
you measure no one has even attempted to
show that 2020 has the least amount of
Fraud and for the reason I gave earlier
which is that absentee ballots are more
vulnerable than normal types of voting
it's very unlikely that when you change
all the rules of an election very often
15 minutes before the election that you
can declare afterward hey by the way
this was the safest